I had one of my friends
um he's in the SEAL Teams and he had a
guy that was that was not to standards
and he brought him into his office and
says hey bro there's no fat seals and
you're fat and it ain't you're gonna
start taking the PRT until you're good
to go so I I sometimes that direct
approach with PRT physical Readiness
test which again in the SEAL Teams
there's not there's not but there's not
a bunch of people tracking you
and there was Years Ago by where the guy
a guy can if you know oh I had a trip
wasn't there for the PRT because like a
command like the Seal team would do one
PRT a year yeah and you'd see it you
know months in advance like oh the PRT
is on October 15th or whatever so if a
guy's like cool
I'm taking leave or I'm gonna go on a
trip October 15th he's not there you do
that three years in a row your your pant
size could be a 46. you know what I'm
saying well what what is it though like
a performance or physical oh it's like a
three mile run push-ups pull-ups swim
something like that so technically you
could get gain a bunch of weight still
pass that thing and be good to go or
what you could but you probably wouldn't
be able to pass it yeah if and you know
it's weird too like this goes back and
forth the Navy has a PRT the regular
Navy and the seals
for a while use the Navy PRT but that
one you probably could be out of shape
like from a seal perspective and still
be able to pass so then the seals made
their own PRT that just to make sure you
don't have anybody that's a that's not
you know because there's no fat seals
like Texas to enforce that role without
having to tell anybody like here's the
PRT if you don't pass it you got to get
on the Run program homie